first of all how was it for you to claim
the cast
of outer banks and had you binged season
one
i did binge season one um i started it
and
and um i started it after i got the
uh call for the audition and i watched
the first one because i
i loved doing my homework right and then
i was
completely hooked i stayed up all night
it's that good right to the end but i um
it's that good and it's um it
draws you in yeah your your character
really shakes things up in season two
i i want to break down that finale
moment first i want to get right into it
john b's dad is alive let's do it
somehow working with carla lambre
apparently
is is she the villain that she is
oh that's a great question i mean i
think my answer to that always is she
doesn't think that she's a villain
right but i um i wouldn't mess with her
i know she has a lot of power she she's
a feisty one she has a lot of power and
she has a lot of entitlement and i think
that she's also
um has nothing to lose right so
i think i think those make for a
dangerous person and my way of thinking
from my experience
so then that being said i feel like
we're meant to believe that john b's dad
was some sort of heroic
man what do you know about their
relationship
and what brought them together
do you have a back you know it was so
well i have a little bit but it was so
fun to see them together
it was so fun to see how much they both
kind of yearned for that
connection you know and and i think that
we
get to explore that sadly um in season
two but
but i have a feeling that that will
happen in the future and that is
exciting to me they're both such lovely
actors and such wonderful humans and and
to see them together they got very
excited about it when we were all in
barbados so i'm
really hopeful we get to see more we'll
see do you think that they're working
together
to keep john b safe or do you think
there's
more to this story i think there's more
to the story
i mean it's jonas right i think they
have some fun things in store
but i for one am looking forward to that
reunion it's a shame it doesn't happen
in season two
i cannot wait for it to happen and
i'm sure i feel that way too
overall what did you think of this
season
and then that plot twist at the end what
were your
overall thoughts oh i was excited um i
didn't you know i didn't see it coming i
didn't have a
like a clear idea of what it would be so
uh when i got the script i was like
no no way because i didn't know if i
would be going to um
barbados or not so that was really the
first clue as they're like hey you know
do you have your passport are you ready
to go and the answer is yes
i was it was really lovely yeah
have you guys started shooting season
three or do you know anything yet
no i don't know anything i think it
starts in the new year
and um i don't know i mean it's one of
those fun shows that i
love because it's very much along the
lines of the of the books that i love
it's a thriller
right so so in an adventure and
in a mystery that's it so i i really
enjoy getting each new script and and i
don't often ask for spoilers or although
sometimes i'm like okay why
not i just want to do this what should i
do here
i just want to know yeah i just want to
know because i'm curious but
yeah i think we'll just have to wait and
see what would you love to see
i know nothing's been written yet but
what would you love to see from carla
in season three if it were up to you oh
my gosh that's
a great question i would like to kind of
fully explore
her relationship and also kind of like
her
i guess her relationship with her own
mortality
i think that we have these creatures in
life who think that they're above
everything you know they're above the
law they're above the rules of society
they're above all of that and i think
that um
i think that carly thinks that she's
above death so i think that that's a
very interesting thing
to explore um that kind of hubris and a
character it's fascinating to me
and of course you know i loved playing
with the kids like i found them to be
the most delightful funny irreverent
fascinating people so it'd be fun to
have more things with them as well
i love that the cast is i feel like i've
been interviewing them since before
season one came out and they're just the
nicest
kids they're so nice and they were so
welcoming and they're lovely they're
they're humble they're kind they're
excited you know all the things that you
love to see
yeah nobody's like too cool everybody's
really just doing
doing their thing and happy to be there
and doing the work and yeah i'm nuts
about them
yeah the kids we do find out in season
two that pope
is related to denmark tannie carla
really wants ross of santo domingo
where will that whole story look i
really wanted it yeah yeah she wanted it
so bad
she was like this is going to add years
yeah
um yeah well i mean you know this is the
difference between life and death
it is for her where where do you see
that storyline potentially going
it's fascinating to think that there
could be a miracle and that she could be
healed obviously she can't
um exist without the hope of that
you know so so that is a that's kind of
a fun thing
to play so of course you know in a dream
sequence where where carla becomes a
superhero
it would be really fun to see her be
healed and to kind of
come back to life i'm fascinated by the
psychological
um ramifications of that as well like
what happens when um
our minds like leave our bodies to
health right
like what what that looks like you know
as well as the idea of
of how can we heal ourselves and then
what happens when we can't
where does that go for us which i think
is actually
even more interesting when we have to
give in to
mortality to the end of our lives that's
really interesting as well so i i mean
the whole thing is really kind of fun
for me whatever avenue they choose to go
down is going to be
a wild ride as it was from the beginning